indeed with alex linderman who stays
right there at the top of the
leaderboard thanks to this draw alex i
got to tell you i was the only one in
the studio who had confidence in you
that you were going to pull it off
coming from brooklyn and your fine play
congratulations on that but i will say
you did have me scared and i imagine you
were scared too oh yeah uh definitely
the game didn't go according to plan um
i thought uh the move queen c7 in the
early opening
might be a surprise to him uh it's not
the most common move the most common
move there is knight h6
and there's some other moves but queen
c7 i think is very interesting
i worked a lot on that line and um he
and the main line actually after queen
c7 is c3 but darius pretty quickly
played d3 and c3 which i believe is
actually the most difficult line for
black and it was a bit disappointing to
me that he knew the line you know and he
played it so quickly and yeah i know
that um this end game might be a bit
difficult for black i think this is kind
of the best
white can get in this line i thought
came to the conclusion that it's kind of
holdable but actually i
i think there is um
one new i'm not sure if e5 was in my
prep because the thing is
i think i remember a position that maybe
it's queen takes b6 first and then e5
and then i think i'm going 98 and i
think i vaguely remembered something
like that and then of course there's
also queen takes yeah something like
that and then there's also bishop e3
instead or bishop f4
but i think e5 right away maybe i
didn't analyze um because the thing is
now i can't play 98 because of queen h4
right so i have to take on d4 i'm pretty
sure
yeah queen h4 i think it's should be h6
and knight g5 right so i'm pretty sure i
have to take on d4 but then after he
took on d4 i realized wait a second um i
remember that in the other line he's
taking on b6 and i have different pawn
structures so i realized probably i'm
not playing 98 here and then of course i
had a deep thing because i have to
compare rook e8 or knight g4 and maybe
even some knight d5 position yeah and i
guess i misplayed it slightly and maybe
i didn't go for the right idea and yeah
and ended up having to suffer and i
thought somehow i'll still get good
drawing chances but then it became
quite difficult and i think in a lot of
lines i was surviving by a temple so
yeah i mean i definitely obviously that
this didn't go according to plan but
can all things considered obvious at
this point i'm very happy with the to
survive this with the drone right this
end game looked horrible for you and as
you said you managed to survive in the
end he gave you this end game that we
all have to study the rook be cutting
off
the king by three files the a pawn going
down you went into a deep think we saw
you
calculating calculating before you
played h5 tell us about your thoughts at
that moment well i i wanted to make sure
i'm not uh going into a losing line
right i had a lot of time that's the
thing so there's no point of rushing
that that was the last critical moment
right so like i can't use my time for
the next game so
you know given the fact that it was
probably the last critical moment of the
game it made sense to try to really make
sure and because and not miss a detail
right
and
and because in a lot of lines i was
actually
making it by a tempo i was making a draw
in that line right so i wanted to make
sure i didn't like
skip a move for him or something like
that or for myself right so i just was
double checking my calculation um but
i'm pretty sure i have to play this h5
idea anyways so
yeah it's uh if i can ask you alex just
your instinct
in this exact position after you played
h7 h6
did you think you were drawing or losing
like just
you know i was speaking i never thought
i was like losing but i i didn't want to
believe that
i i think in this particular position i
thought i was drawing um and i because i
saw a lot of lines where he gets the
king to b5 but then i thought i have
always if when i'm taking on f3 he takes
on a4 i have ideas like rook four trying
to exchange into an end game for an end
game or even h5 and then i get counter
play and i was fairly certain that i'm
drawing there but yeah of course it's
quite and then of course he was thinking
for a long time here trying to find
something i mean i looked at f4 for him
as well but yes this was our main move
and this was the line we thought has
chances yeah here's the thing though
about a force so it's actually very
important that i don't automatically
exchange the other pawn right because
otherwise i'm going to be stuck with
that a4 pawn that's right you know
normally i'm happy you know down in the
pawn to exchange uh
the pawns right and then but in this
particular structure with that pawn on a
four so misplaced i actually my only
chance is getting counter played because
of the g4 pawns so i think here i was
gonna play something like king of six
and wait and i didn't see
for sure house yeah king g5
i mean
yeah rg2
uh yeah rook takes b2
ah like that uh-huh
okay um
oh like this yeah this is faster by a
tempo for sure it depends on a4 so
what's happening is he actually winning
here
we know which is the most amazing thing
of all time here was a tempo that you
did lose but there was like the it
wasn't there's still the rook a2 no this
is the line where we got king b6 and a7
okay ah yeah and actually before the
king could get right actually that
position if he gets king b6 and a7 and
that end game is a i think that might be
losing right or maybe he's losing that's
losing yeah that's what i thought that's
why i was thinking a long time right
because first at first i thought yeah
he's getting that in but then i realized
he's not right it was like tempo tempo
right i can't that's the position i just
can't miscalculate otherwise i lose
right so but the thing is i i don't i
didn't really see what else i can do
anyway so i kind of had to play this way
exactly fortunately he wrote his work
back to the b for the b3 square and that
pulled you by its info and gave you the
forced line yeah no this is this is a
lucky break you know just the fact that
the lines kind of survive i'm surviving
by a temple i apologize you know
normally in order to
get into the top three or especially win
the tournament like that you need some
lucky breaks at some point so the fact
that you know i was able to win that end
game against sam you know at the end it
was like 50 50 if i'm gonna win it and
then to survive this one i mean i feel
like in in terms of end games i feel
like luck has gone my way and now
hopefully i'll be able to play better
next few rounds got a rest day to think
about it three rounds to go oh i
definitely need that rest day after
after these last four games and
especially this long suffering game who
do you play to close out the tournament
yeah so i'm playing double white against
sam shankland and then i'm playing
against fabi and then i'm playing in the
last round against lazarus brazil
so yeah it's um it's not easy but um you
know we'll see i like the fact that i
have two whites so
good luck the rest of the way thank you
thank you absolutely alex
congratulations and the sprint to the
finish we'll be watching closely